nothing transforms a good movie villain
into a great one like a killer wardrobe
a badass backstory and a compelling
argument these villains all had a pretty
good point even if we were too busy
hating them to realize it we should say
up front that we firmly believe the Dark
Knight's Joker to be a raving sociopath
and an absolute menace to society but
fear us out it's sometimes hard to argue
with this philosophy that human beings
are not meant to be confined within a
structured society and yes human beings
find ways to remind us of the delicate
nature of social contracts every day you
see this is how crazy Batman's made
Gotham if you want order in Gotham
Batman must take off his mask and turn
himself in every day he doesn't people
will die
Joker's fairy versus fairy experiments
may have failed to bring Gotham to its
knees but that doesn't mean he wasn't
right about a certain Gothamites nature
yup we're talking about da Harvey Dent
better known as two-face Joker tortured
the noble lawman emotionally and
physically early in the film before
breaking dents psyche and turning him
loose on a coin flipping killing spree
bringing Gotham's golden boy down into
the trenches with the rest of the city's
criminals was Joker's masterpiece it was
only tarnished by Batman and chief
Gordon spinning the biggest web of lies
that Gotham has ever seen which sort of
feels like a loss for the supposed good
guys count yourself lucky if you are not
the leader of the free world when the
apocalypse begins that's just where Karl
Anheuser found himself when the end
began in the brain was disaster flick
2012
just exactly how long these things
expect to hold us in place captain
they're just meant to withstand the
first impact of the waves mister
well Anheuser was an antagonistic
presence throughout the film
he didn't achieve full-on villain status
until he warded the heroic efforts of
Jackson Curtis to save his family by
unceremoniously slamming the door to
salvation in the Curtis family's
collective faces it's a brutal moment to
be sure but it's important to remember
that if Anheuser hadn't shut the doors
the world ending flood outside might
have found its way in it would have
killed all the would-be survivors aboard
the ark and that would have meant the
end of humanity so yeah Anheuser could
have been nicer about everything but
seriously he had to close those doors
sure Daniel Craig plays an excellent
bond but the success of 2012's
box-office smashing Skyfall owes a lot
to Javier Bardem performance as scorned
secret agent turned vengeful cyber
terrorist Raoul Silva well there's no
question that Silva falls on the baddie
side of the spectrum
he's also well a human a terrible awful
no-good human but a human nonetheless I
will what do you say to that waste of
good scotch he's talented sure and he's
hyper intelligent but he's also tortured
sound familiar there are definite
parallels between Silva a former mi6
agent who was abandoned to be tortured
by the Chinese and bond in fact it was
Silva sympathetic backstory that
attracted Bardem to the part the actor
told Fox News here there is a broken
person what I like the most is there is
a clear motive
we understand he is very human and this
is powerful I was attracted to the
villain because I thought he was a nice
guy I could see it in his eyes
we're not sure we agree with Bardem but
will admit Silva's about a sympathetic
as Bond villains get and that's got to
count for something you see we are the
last two rats we can either eat each
other
don't eat everyone else he was one of
the biggest action heroes of the day but
if Top Gun were real life there's no way
that Tom Cruise's Pete maverick Mitchell
would be a popular guy the antagonist of
the 80s classic Val Kilmer's Tom Iceman
Kazansky on the other hand very well
might be as top dog at the Naval Air
Station Miramar top gun school he spent
years training to be the best young
pilot around so of course he's going to
have a problem when this upstart
maverick turns up and displays a blatant
disregard for everyone's safety guys
really are Cowboys what's your problem
kazansky you're everyone's problem
that's because every time you go up in
the air you're unsafe at one stage
reports emerged suggesting that crews
and Kilmer's onset relationship mirrored
that of their characters but if there
was ever any truth to this then it's
clearly all water under the bridge as
the pair are reuniting for Top Gun to
Kilmer was sidelined with throat cancer
for a while but he has revealed that
he's fit and well enough to reprise the
role of Iceman in the upcoming sequel I
don't like you because you're dangerous
that's right nice man I am dangerous